this is a production of Cornell
University
so why why South and Southeast Asia you
know we'll talk in more specifics about
the course that Marvin and I are
involved with here in a few minutes but
but let me speak to this issue just for
a few minutes one is one reason that
we've about 16 or 17 years ago started
focusing on South and Southeast Asia was
the rapidly changing agriculture and
food systems and in those countries and
expanding economies important
development challenges you know we've
been going some of us have been going to
India for 30 plus years and every few
years you if you speak to the same
farmers about the water table in their
bore holes in the Punjab or in Haryana
or yupi they'll they'll talk about the
number of meters it's dropped climate
change so a number of development
challenges but also a lot of innovation
in India is one of the things that
really attracts me a few students have
been to south or Southeast Asia before
and and then recent improvements to
infrastructure that accommodates fairly
large groups in relatively rural areas
because that's where we go we we tend to
get off the beaten path the it's a an
interesting place for our students
ethnically very diverse diverse
religious affiliations this is certainly
not the entire list tropical cropping
systems for most Cornell students is the
first time to see tumeric growing or
black pepper or cacao growing and being
processed or to pluck tea leaves or to
pick coffee or to taste
rambutan or jackfruit so it's it's a
rich experience for many of our students
from that perspective as well tremendous
variation in crops
farming systems farming philosophies
fascinating cultures really fascinating
culture and Marvin must have snuck this
one into and and of course Marvin's main
interest has to do with the fact that
it's warm in January and it's not warm
in Ithaca in January but seriously the
decision to focus this field course in
South and Southeast Asia about 17 years
ago had some really important
pedagogical dimensions as well first of
all we had really outstanding long-term
collaborators and three of them are in
this room the faculty from India right
now that we're eager to host us many
alumni in all sorts of organizations in
India that were very eager to host us we
had experienced and well-connected
campus champions JB ramens one of them
Syed Rizwan food science
Ronnie Kaufmann Peter Hobbs had worked
there for 20-some meters for four CIMMYT
so we had a number of people here that
had the sorts of connections and
experiences and knowledge to make a
really rich field course and then as I
just mentioned very briefly a moment ago
India is a place where we can see really
creative and successful innovation in
agriculture and in rural development
it's known around the world for the
innovative women's self-help group
movement the Ammal dairy cooperative the
Rajasthan watershed management
initiatives in LOD the list could go on
and on and on India's is really a place
where you can find some of the most
instructive some of the most impressive
some of the most inspirational
innovation when it comes to agricultural
development yes lots of challenges but
also a lot of talent and a lot of
innovation there as well and I think I
mentioned prominent alums moment ago we
have we have many of them and in this
course on this is the course that this
experience is packaged with it's
actually a sequence of courses a full
year sequence the title of its
agriculture and developing nations the
interdepartmental interdisciplinary
course has been offered for 50
consecutive years this is a 50th
anniversary for the course more than
1,800 students have participated in that
course over the last 50 years it it
reads like a who's who in lis among
leaders in international agriculture in
rural development I had a chance to look
over that list a few weeks ago many many
faculty at this institutional back up
here in a minute but no more famous
alums than these three right here your
colleague on the right there Chris Wayne
I think participated in the first one
didn't he Jamie yeah 50 years ago he was
a student in in the first at that time
it was called international agriculture
402 Chris Wayne bill fried Ronnie
Kauffman many other faculty members
maybe didn't participate as students but
but have been on the faculty they've
been dozens of people including many
that are currently in the in sips who
have participated as faculty members I
don't know Ken did you do it as a Ken
much in the back there you did probably
Ian merwin did Jane Mount Pleasant has
many many
of for the faculty your colleagues have
participated in in this course the
looking at the alumni you know we find
many people who have gone on to be
leaders in the international AG research
centers the cg system we have many that
are professors not only at Cornell but
around the u.s. land grant system and
around the world leaders in in the World
Bank in the Asian Development Bank in
the Latin American inter-american
Development Bank USAID foreign AG
service of USDA and on and on and on we
go the private sector you know we bump
into our students while we're in the
field who who worked for pioneer seeds
or Cargill or Mahindra American alums
who who went on to make a career in Asia
purposely interdisciplinary we not only
have students from all across cowls but
over the years we've had students from
the law school last year I think we had
three from the vet school payal our
engineering planning and so on and one
of the comments that that stuck with me
that that bill Frye made recently when
he was describing the experience he had
49 or 50 years ago in this course as a
student is that most of the time when he
in the intervening four plus decades his
his gone overseas to work he works on
one focused thing in one place and he
said the only time in his nearly 50
years of traveling overseas and
observing agricultural development the
only time that he's had a chance to see
things as whole systems very
holistically was was in this particular
course because students see everything
from agricultural inputs on
a lot of time on farms processing value
addition and so on in in food and and
now in textiles as well human ecology as
a as a cohort of of textile students to
travel with us local contacts allow us
to get to places that we we wouldn't get
to if we were just touring we get into
rural houses small farms businesses
farmers oftentimes there are instructors
or local researchers and development
practitioners there are expert resource
persons learning from peers the Cornell
students will when we go to India and in
January they'll be learning from the 15
students in their faculty who are here
right now and we hope that the students
that are here for the next two weeks
will learn from from our students as
well learn something about American
agriculture and food system so there's
that reciprocity also among faculty
faculty we learn from counterparts from
India Myanmar and it's very a very
experiential form of learning you know
they're not over there sitting in a
classroom they're over there in the
field speaking with with farmers
researchers practitioners as I mentioned
the the class structure it's it's a full
year course we have resource persons
that come during the preliminary the
preparatory course so for example last
year a year ago right now we were
preparing to go this past January to
Myanmar and one of the guest presenters
for our fall class that we were able to
attract to campus for two days with our
students and faculty was the first US
ambassador to me
who had you know us hadn't had
diplomatic relations for decades during
the military regime regime in in Myanmar
so Derek Mitchell came in and spent a
significant time with us in giving a
sort of a front-row seat perspective to
the changes that have taken place over
the last four or five years in Myanmar
the students do a lot of sharing of
their international experiences as I
mentioned before when we're in country
or when they're visiting us we spend
some time on campuses and in the field
together we have Humphrey fellows almost
every year that that participate they're
mid-career professionals and then after
the January field trip we continue on
with a spring semester course and the
students write papers together and this
past year those group papers several
were submitted to the Cornell policy
review and will be published this fall
so just a couple minutes about India you
know we we know that it's it's the
world's largest democracy it's really
wrestling with its its own identity in
many ways and its own development
trajectory soon to be the most populous
country in the world oh just about 1.3
billion people so more than one out of
every six people that walk on this earth
is from India millions of farmers the
last census that I saw agricultural
census in India had the number of
individual farms that I think around 120
million and most of those
small or marginal farms in terms of size
and a fair amount even though it's got a
very large and rapidly growing middle
class which a lot of Americans don't
realize it also has you know large
amount of rural poverty and food
insecurity a few statistics they
certainly don't tell the whole story I
think another thing we know about India
in this country or we read about here
about in the media is that it's an
established global leader in information
communication technology computer
software and just bring to your
attention you know some some differences
in in GDP the thing that strikes our
students when they go to India is that
second set of things that are circled
density you know when our students go to
India they almost invariably remarked
about the number of people if you come
from upstate New York I happen to come
from a county in north central
Pennsylvania in the Allegheny plateau I
still have a farm in that area and the
population density there is four people
per square kilometer and in India is
four hundred and ten and in parts of
India like Oda Pradesh it's probably 12
or 1300 or something like that so it's a
very densely populated country it's a
young population thus the rapid increase
in in population if we look back just in
1960 that seems like ancient history to
the students in here it doesn't seem
like ancient history to to Marvin and me
but 1960 the population was under five
hundred thousand five hundred million
and now it's about one and a third
billion so very rapidly growing
population a large rural population and
the the thing about obesity one of the
things that's changing there and it's
got the attention of a lot of people in
in the field of nutrition is this
so-called double burden of malnutrition
as a as countries have a growing middle
class as India does middle-class people
eat differently than poor people and so
we're seeing fairly rapid increases in
obesity and in many developing countries
as the middle class grows and let me
just point out in closing that this is
the the area of India
Marvin's going to speak to Myanmar this
is the area of India that we've been
working in no we have students here
today that are from Assam up here in the
Northeast how many raise your hands if
you from us um they're from Assam
Agricultural University up there and
students raise your hands if you're from
University of Agricultural Sciences and
dharwad okay that's in Karnataka known
in this area and so those are our
partners this year those were our
partners a couple years ago the last
time we we went to India and so in
January of this year we'll be in that
area for about two and a half weeks I'm
going to stop there and Marvin's going
to talk about me and Mark so the other
place that we go as a class which used
to be called Burma and it used to be the
breadbasket of Southeast Asia and one of
the reasons is it just has an incredible
climate from you know tropical sea level
environments to mountains where you can
grow apples and cool season crops lots
of why
in soil resources but now it has the
lowest yields per acre of any Southeast
Asian country and I'll tell you why in a
second it's primarily now a rice based
diet that people we people he does eat
rice all the time and there's not a lot
of diversity there and very low levels
of fruit and vegetable consumption part
of the reason for this poor performance
of crops and diet that's not very strong
is because of the government and this
situation that happened after the
British they got independence in 1948
from the Brits but then there was a coup
in 1962 kind of took over the country
for about 50 years very strong
centralized military dictatorship that
told people if you want to go land or
you O'Bannon's land you have to grow
rice because they didn't want people
starving a didn't want a revolt
so you rule with an iron fist and they
rule for a long time and that was when
she was in prison and you got the Nobel
Peace Prize and all that a lot of strife
in that country as recently as two
thousand club there was a ceasefire with
Qin state which is one of the several
states in Myanmar but is continuously
ethnic violence in bikinis Davis or
hinga people as you read about it could
chin and Shan State
there's gonna go on for years and years
we're just now hearing about George
Engle people but that's been going on
for for quite a while but the military
government allowed elections in 2016 the
first non-military
leader was installed but in the truth
the civilian leaders does not control
the military the military still control
several ministries they also have a
guarantee number of seats in Congress so
the military even though it looks like
on the surface is a democratically
elected government then you know we pull
back some of the sanctions and so forth
to help that the military still rules of
the iron fist and still it's causing
trouble over a routine state here's
where Myanmar is it's next to India and
it borders Bangladesh in India to the
north China and Laos and Thailand but
that's how long it's almost like Chile
where it's it's really long country with
a lot of different growing regions and
all kinds of
fruits can be grown there but the
problem is it's also a very poor country
and if you look at the income per worker
farm worker in Myanmar it's way way down
at the bottom people just don't make a
lot of money I was a high rate of
poverty and a lot of children
underweight because they don't get
enough protein and or dye or fruits and
vegetables because they so much rice the
yields per acre are very low in
Myanmar's I mentioned earlier here's
some examples of tomato yields if you
look at what the yield is in Myanmar
compared to California like four times
less same way with cabbage watermelon
lettuce asparagus you know you just
don't produce the yields that we do us a
lot of is because they don't have good
water systems for irrigation they don't
have good fertilizer sources so their
production is really low and people
don't eat a lot of this stuff anyway
when they grow it so this is fruit
consumption and all these other
Southeast Asian countries this is a
global consumption of fruit per capita
on average almost 80 kilograms per
person per year and look down here is me
mr yeah less than 20 and as I suppose is
the same way even when you're provided
the culture is we don't need fruits and
vegetables so as a result there's a lot
of malnutrition in Qin state I know that
rate of childhood stunting is around 40%
it's really really high they have a
strained infrastructure this is the
major this is the one agricultural
university in Myanmar and this is a
department of horticulture building the
main university they also have these 14
AG institutions scattered around the
country and this is one of them and
there's a reported Horticulture
Department and here's a photo from one
of the labs and that's what it looks
like so there they're really there's a
long way to go there for them and it's
really difficult to come in to help
because it's still so centrally managed
that for us to even go there and visit
we had to get a letter from the capital
city granting us permission to go and
and then when we ask to borrow the
curriculum to look at they had to make a
bunch of phone calls to get permission
even give us the first-year curriculum
like this is the list of courses the
students had to have because they were
afraid of doing something that wouldn't
be in line with the central government's
wishes so it's a incredibly wonderful
people very friendly but very
challenging to work in here's a some of
the roads they give money anything they
have to these magnificent abilities so
when the students are there they're
confronted with all kinds of issues and
so the questions that were we asked them
to answer and write papers about are
these complicated questions you know
they're not just specific like all for
example Carey meant to this 120 million
number of farmers in this country how do
you kind of extension reach 120 million
people yeah how do you promote
mechanization in a country where if you
put people out of work what are they
gonna do you know all kinds of
interesting really challenging questions
and the list goes on how do you promote
more fruit and vegetable consumption in
a place like Myanmar when we know that
they need it but the culture doesn't
really embrace it how do you how do we
scientists talk to people in places
where they use these alternative methods
to grow food crops like Vedic practices
a chant they use phases of the Moon and
those of us from a Western perspective
we say well that might not be you know
what we would do but you've got to be
respectful people who've been doing this
for seven thousand years right so
there's all kinds of challenges that our
students get it
she has to face and do it so how's this
trip affect students individually we're
gonna have a Marcus share his experience
gone on a trip last year to Myanmar okay
all right so I had the pleasure of going
on the trip to Myanmar with Cavey Terry
and Marvin and I was asked to just kind
of give my perspective as they already
mentioned we wrote a paper I was a part
of a three-person group who wrote a
paper dealing with issues of extension
and infrastructure that's getting
published and for me to talk about the
impact it had on me I want to just talk
about three things that I really noticed
when I was in Myanmar when we were
visiting all these different small
villages and farmers and also just
getting to know the students you guys
are really lucky that you're here now to
meet with the students that you'll be
travelling with that was something that
I had wished we had been able to do
because by the time we started
connecting with the students that seems
like our trip was already over so for me
I really appreciated the work ethic that
all the students had it really struck a
chord with me because they're not only
taking full class load credits wise and
trying to become a plant breeders plant
geneticists when they're first
generation students but they're also
doing so with all their books being in
English not even the language they're
primarily speaking so I knew for me it
really made me think about how I've had
so many hard classes here as a Cornell
student I can imagine trying to learn
plant physiology or like plant genetics
in Burmese I just it was really
impressive to like see how hard that
they are all working to better their
community the second thing that I really
noticed was just and they kind of
touched on this the lack of information
in infrastructure for information so
many of the villages we visited had
maybe one person had a cell phone that
they could run on a generator to charge
like here I can just Google anything
like it's weird when I don't have access
to sir internet or you know resources
such as Marvin and Terry I can literally
walk I literally weekly walk into
Marvin's office sometimes just ask him a
question
so I really was that was something I
really wanted to make sure that I did
better was utilizing the access to
education and like public sources as a
Cornell student and then the final thing
and they this was also touched on was
every village we went to even though
they might have been growing rice to
sell that was more nutritious
nutritionally dense or better for you
nutritionally they were all all the
farmers grew their own landrace
varieties and we're so proud of it and
that pride in like what they were
growing and the education what education
they had access to via extension agents
even if it was limited they were super
proud of being able to like contour farm
on a hillside or grow ginseng to sell at
market but at the same time they were
super proud of what they were growing
and would feed us their rice and it was
just a really humbling experience to see
how proud they were of it and it kind of
like really resonated with me like I
want to I guess our takeaway is for me I
really want to be more engaged in the
communities I'm in as a senior in plant
science I'm a peer mentor to five new
students and it's a really unique
opportunity to give back and I kind of
think that before this trip I would have
said oh yeah peer mentoring is a great
idea someone should do that but after
the trip like getting to know these
students who all they want to do is like
learn to then give back really was a
catalyst for me to want to do just that
and that also with our publication in
the fall we tackled different aspects
like we had what
fifteen students or how many groups we
headed six different groups of varying
lengths varying subjects and that's a
really also unique opportunity to work
with people who weren't necessarily in
your major or like have a different
perspective to also then give back to a
community and kind of the final thing is
just realizing like yeah I feel busy as
a student here everyone does but there's
always that like extra half hour hour I
can carve out of my day to either work
on my personal relationships with other
students or professional relationships
with professors - I guess catalyze
change so that's pretty much my five
minutes and what Marcus didn't say is a
lot of these countries the students in
college they get up at 6:00 in the
morning and do a couple of hours of
field work before they go to class they
come back in the afternoon and finish up
the field work so you got a real
experimental learning but it's very hard
work and pretty amazing so quickly at
the finish I'm going to just show you a
bunch of slides really quickly India how
we travel by bus sometimes they travel
by train
India is a very beautiful country in
many places but I want you to notice
it's a little bit hazy and there's this
layer here of smog and for those of us
for the states where we're used to
pretty clear skies you know it's pretty
hazy and a lot of is because there's
still a lot of burning that goes on in
India and a lot of garbage is burn and
wood fires it creates a haze over much
of the country
there's also we're not used to seeing
your sewage along the roads and we all
have very strong regulations about that
in India that's not the case but also
the very beautiful places palaces it's
also very crowded as Terry said lots of
people I'm gonna show you a little just
a little example
[Applause]
[Music]
students in India might say what's the
big deal but for us it's car this is
this is one of the best nice everybody
remember that one of the first video
games that came out was called Frogger
about watch you stop there for us it's
just pretty amazing we'd wait to like to
change the crosswalk so a lot of wealth
in India we don't think of India
necessary but this is a wedding that was
going outside one of the hotels you
stayed in it was like a three-day affair
and a very elaborate with the stage and
all that teri mentioned water a lot of
farmers pull water out of these bore
holes or they carry water from a central
spot a lot of time spent carrying water
a typical farm in India you know few
cows and chickens everybody has a
motorcycle to get around there women
lots of different crops some of the
faces of some of the people I wanted you
to notice this feel of tomatoes here
there's some women picking tomatoes and
there's this fella here he's sitting in
the ground under the tree and again one
of the things is really hard for us for
this country to kind of accept these big
strong gender roles so these women
around the hot Sun picking the tomatoes
carrying aback
you know now he's leaning down taking it
out it's getting hot hot out there she's
in the shade tree and then he sits in
counsel Tomatoes that's his job
so it's you know here it's a lot more
equal in terms of that sense but there's
very distinct gender roles here we see
tumeric being harvested I seen that
somebody know what this is yeah
still no guesses this is nice right and
this is nutmeg yeah and they're
separating it and getting ready to sell
it drying in the Sun a lot of
intercropping coconut palms coffee
chocolate growing under the trees and if
you haven't seen chocolate before how
about this plant wait no yeah black
pepper a lot of rice rice paddies
interesting markets that was a gourd
called as a heart of palm banana flowers
bananas you can buy birds at the farmers
market rabbits anything you want bees
it's not the same species we have but
grabbe's sugar cane we see it saw it cut
by hand and processed in these big vats
where they boil down the SAP basically
and make sugar out of it
corn processing value-added chicken
farms tea yeah got a chance to pick tea
and crush it and for a minute and brew
our own tea this is a large-scale tea
factory where they're drawing the leaves
and then different teas we got a chance
to taste a banana planning plan research
papaya
or bananas uh I'm here from Darwin these
are a couple of graduate students on a
Sunday afternoon a Dharwad collecting
data just want to point that out
the grad students
there's during plows and repositories
here's one for some of the green crops
of dry land grains we visited Tamil
Nadu's a famous Agricultural College
that has a lot of fruit growing the
Indian Institute of rice research I like
this place the pest repellent cafeteria
sounds like a good name then a farm for
retired elephants so we're used to being
around people and they like to interact
with people so I got a chance to climb
up in the elephant in Myanmar another
really interesting place Chris Wien who
went with me in April of this year said
he's never been to a country where the
people were more uniformly friendly as
Myanmar really incredible a lot of
people were this paste on your face it's
sandalwood they rub it on her face is
sort of like a sunscreen as a way to
keep the skin looking fresh
most of Myanmar's in a Delta region are
WA Oddie River runs through there but
there's a lot of mountain regions as
well we were there with a class we
mainly stayed in a lower Delta region
lots of rice grown but it does have
mountains and this is qin state where
it's a lot more mountainous there's our
bus drove around we were at the airport
and mandalay and some guy came running
on the bus because i can't believe it on
the Cornell graduate I can't believe it
busted for now in front of it it's
really exciting and I want you to notice
the license plate here looks like it's
like peed a little bit right so what
happens is in the mr each state has a
different license plate a different
color and if you happen to like want to
drive in another state doesn't the right
color you just got the paintbrush
license plate the right color so you
don't get stopped by the police and once
in a while on these dirt roads you know
something breaks down here's a truck
broke down and we couldn't get through
we had a bus so we all had to get out
and push this truck all the way so he
got through
some beautiful pagodas that were built
around 1000 AD by the first boost it
came in to Myanmar a lot of pagodas
spectacular this one's the Shwedagon
pagoda President Obama went there a
couple of years ago on Yan Xiu Qi often
makes addresses from the Shwedagon
pagoda it's a really incredible
beautiful spot a lot of people come
there to meditate and pray a lot of the
hilltops they're covered with pagodas of
some sort in Myanmar very beautiful and
spectacular again for our students it
was little bit hard to see this
beautiful gold-plated you know pagodas
at the same time most of the people in
the country are poor and for a lot of
Buddhists it's like well we don't need
to accumulate a lot of wealth in this
world we'll give it to the monastery for
these pagodas and then we'll be rewarded
in the afterlife with something better a
lot of places where women are not
allowed to go if you're in Myanmar
here's another sacred place prohibited
foreigners I can go female and males
under 18 if you do something bad there a
lot of people are literate but you know
here's a picture it shows you what
happens if you fool around with another
woman you know you got in trouble if you
if you gossip about somebody over there
and you know that will cut your tongue
out and how if you booze it up too much
you know you got waterboarded there or
something a lot of interesting stuff one
of the things we a couple of really cool
things we did there was we took hot-air
balloon rides in the morning before the
Sun came up over all those pagodas and
you can see all those two gurus out
there and as the sun's coming up and it
hits the gold root for the pagodas is
just spectacular beautiful
so these animals are being replaced with
some of these crude machines but these
machines can be used for lots of
purposes and they're becoming very
popular these are the pull behind
tractors this is interesting we if we
were there in the dry season but it
rained one day we were there during dry
season and the growers freaked out and
we went to visit a vineyard to the next
day and they were spraying fungicide
because of rain and look they're just
mixing like whatever they can find
together and better put it up look at
this fury Dan out there which we don't
use anymore this fella here was mixing
it in his tank and they were pumping it
out in the hose and they were hauling
the hose down the row and then somebody
there was the protective equipment on
was spraying the initiate gloves was
spraying the grates and yeah we would
yep last thing I want to show you is we
went to this inle lake where as a place
that got lots of flooding after
rainfalls and the water level weapon
down and the people's gardens to get
flooded out so what they did was they
decided they were gonna move the village
to the water and build these mats where
they could put the vegetables on the mat
and when the liquid level would rise the
vegetables would just float up on the
mast so we would go through these
villages and drive right through the
eggplants and the tomatoes to float
pretty cool stuff dragon fruit alright
so don't tell me times up so we'll stop
right now and that's see if you have
questions this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu